let's see if you can pass this logic  test Alice Bob and Charlie are one of  each type a truth teller always tells  the truth a liar always lies and a spy  can lie or tell the truth Alice says she  is not a truth teller Bob says he is not  a spy and Charlie says he is not a liar  what type is Charlie truth teller liar  spy or there's not enough information  to solve this problem let's start with  Alice if Alice were a truth teller she  cannot State she is not a truth teller  If instead Alice were a liar then she  would always lie but saying she is not a  truth teller would be true therefore  Alice is a spy  from here suppose that Bob were a liar  in that case he would always lie but  saying he is not a spy would be true  since spy is already taken Bob must be a  truth teller this means that Charlie  must be a liar and the correct answer is  Choice B